Chris we've been ahead of the curve on
this I'm not trying to pat ourselves on
the back but let me pat ourselves on the
back yes we've been making people aware
that there's something up with the
Seahawks and Russel Wilson and Wilson
now says he wants his contract by April
15 he's made it clear via his visit to
Jimmy Fallon he wants to be the
highest-paid player in football so if
you're the Seahawks what do you do about
this yeah I mean to me this would be
something again you know I don't expect
anything to be done by April 15 do you I
mean I don't think that's even realistic
at this point it doesn't sound like I
feel like we're gonna hurt rumors that
things were you know farther down the
road as far as contract talks and things
like that
so I have no idea where they're at but
if I'm the if I'm the Seattle Seahawks
I'm trying to get this done this
offseason I am Russell Wilson without
question the most famous most noddle you
know notable player in the history of
the Seattle Seahawks
Russell Wilson without question is one
of the five best quarterbacks in
football and I just think if I'm the
Seattle Seahawks I don't let a talent
like that out the door and I would try
to find a way right now hey fine if you
got to make him the highest-paid
quarterback in football right now that's
that's all fine and dandy I think in
with the way the salary caps going right
Mike and everything they're you know
okay you're the richest quarterback this
year three years from now it will be you
know the 10th highest-paid quarterback
in football and I think that will help
out the Seattle Seahawks and the
long-term long-term prospects of their
football team to kind of get it get out
ahead of this I really think what's
going on is this and I'm gonna explore
whether or not this theory has any merit
once we finish up today but I think that
the Seahawks have been trying to get him
to sign a long-term deal he's been
resisting it and eventually he said all
right here's what it's gonna be I want
to be the highest-paid player in
football and it's got to be done by
April 15 otherwise no long-term deal I
think he wants to do the Kirk Cousins
one year at a time because he knows at
some point he forces his way to the open
market and the Seahawks want to sign him
on the open market so be it they can but
this is a way to bring some of that NBA
attitude into the NFL we've seen it with
Kirk Cousins we've seen it with Antonio
Brown and we
be seeing with Russell Wilson and I know
it's out of character but just the fact
that there would be a story that he's
given them this deadline this artificial
deadline of April 15 for a long-term
contract that's out of character yeah so
hey he's 30 now he's got other issues
he's considering he's made a certain
amount of money he sees how much more he
can make and he knows there's a finite
number of years that he can make it
right now is the time to shake as much
as you can out of the trees and I think
one way or the other he's going to make
34 million over the next four years and
it's either gonna be as part of a
long-term contract Chris or it's gonna
be franchise tag 20 20 franchise tag 20
21 and if the Seahawks are willing to do
it fifty 2.4 million for the franchise
tag in 2022 I don't know that a
character I was just gonna say to
because he is a guy that seems pretty
straightforward business oriented
understands the full scope of the league
he always kind of threatens about this
I'm gonna go play baseball for a week
with the New York Yankees you're right
you're right he never says this is the
this is the first time he has deviated
in any way from the carefully manicured
go Hawks image and that was the way that
they would do it in the locker room
behind his back when you know the
rough-and-tumble guys were there and
resented the fact that he was kind of
management among them and now that
they've built the team around him it's
even more imperative that they keep him
that he's got a ton of leverage here I
mean a ton a ton and they're even gonna
pay they're gonna pay him Aaron Rodgers
Plus or they're gonna be paying him over
the next four years the same amount and
then they may not have him after the
next three or four years go by here's
what I know and this is the ultimate
multitasking this is text message
exchanges with sources regarding Russell
will so you weren't listening limiting
is what you were saying wasn't listening
to you but someone contacted me with
some information so I had to go back and
forth and play the game a little bit but
here's what I can now report and this
isn't it on PFT yet but it will be soon
enough
Russell Wilson is not gonna hold out he
will be there right every day that the
doors to the facility are open they were
told in late January that the deadline
is April 15 so this isn't
something new right and it is a very
simple proposition get a contract on or
he is gonna go year to year under the
franchise tag now there are factors that
need to be considered when we get into a
long term contract and it isn't going to
simply be pay me what I would make under
the franchise tag over the next four
years the issue of quarterback contract
escalation and we've talked in the past
that you can't have a term in there that
guarantees you a percentage of the
salary cap as the cap goes up and up and
up no team has done that yet but players
have tried to get it how the cap will
increase what will happen under a new
CBA how the money will go up with
legalized gambling how the money will go
up with new national TV deals these are
all things that are projections at this
point but I think Russell Wilson is
going to want to have that accounted for
in some way in this contract it requires
a level of creativity that Aaron Rodgers
wanted in Green Bay and the Packers
wouldn't give it to many eventually
shrugged his shoulders and signed a
normal deal the question is will the
Seahawks do an unconventional deal or
will they let Russell Wilson follow what
is a largely unconventional approach of
one year at a time under the franchise
tag and I think if if Wilson is trying
to take all these factors and turn them
into something quantifiable it's gonna
be less likely that the Seahawks are
gonna bite ya know I you know again
Russell Wilson did the Seattle Seahawks
a solid the last time he negotiated this
contract he was he signed a team
friendly deal he did not hold their feet
over the fire to be the highest-paid guy
or top two or three and all of a
football which he certainly had the
right to do at the time
III would say this if I'm the Seahawks
and I don't know I already said this I
would sign them to a long term deal and
get out in front of it right now because
the year-to-year thing is I think a
franchise killer it's a locker room
killer at the quarterback position other
positions you can get away with it but
we just saw an experiment with the
Washington Redskins with Kirk Cousins
who did the same thing and there was a
disconnect there's a disconnect between
the players and the quarterback in the
locker room the coaches and the
quarterback have a disconnect there and
you question how all-in or emotionally
invested the quarterback is in the
organization
over the long haul in the future when
it's a year-to-year thing in the quarter
a key gonna I might not be here next
year I don't know where this is gonna go
so to me that's where it can really play
an issue with the football team and I
don't see Pete Carroll or John Schneider
who I have a ton of respect for wanting
to do that to their locker room or have
to answer those questions all offseason
for three consecutive offseason so if
I'm then get this done make them the
highest-paid quarterback in all of
football make it a long-term deal so the
yearly the yearly cap it is not a
crushing number and I think that would
be the best way to approach at least in
my opinion yeah and we'll see if they
can work something out but the deadline
is clear it's the start of the off
season program and III think Russell
Wilson if nothing else is a man of his
word and if he says that's the deadline
that's the deadline and it's not gonna
be on April 16 all Russell you know we
changed our mind will agree to it now
that that will be intriguing if they do
all of a sudden cave the day after will
he stick to his guns or will he say okay
if you're gonna give me what I wanted
anyway so be it but but I think that he
really is standing on principle here
he's given them a fair opportunity to
get to where he wants to be and now
we'll see whether or not they get there
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports